I just really think I really believe
this from bottom my heart I think we
only live one time and like and and we
don't act like it
in my 20s I spent an enormous amount of
time hanging out with 90 year old people
and it was unbelievably intense for me
as somebody who was so ambitious at the
time how many of them literally one by
one at airport at airport park or bar
event or event
bar or bar every one of them to a team
started with tell me by your life I'm a
young kid I'm hungry you're old I want
to know talk about your life every one
of them all of them started with my wish
they all wished they wish they worked
harder they wish they spent more time
with their family they wish they didn't
listen to their mom and did what they
wanted to do they wished they wished
they wished the biggest poison in us is
regret it's poison and I push so hard so
hard and we'll through my vehicle which
isn't meditation which isn't health and
wellness which is a nonprofit my
vehicles business you're more than
welcome to tell me about how bad it is
or why you can't because for what but
it's just not true because of anybody
ever did it then you can't